[Music]
we found a photo of you from high school
maybe you can tell us what kind of chap
you were in high school
this is simon helberg uh your high
school photo what kind of guy were you
what were you what were your interests
um
well i think i was hiding my braces in
that bit i think that's why i had like
my hair was that was it's awful awful
image um
and we're going to just keep showing it
i'll stop talking about it
uh yeah i well i was into i was in a
music i wanted to be i i was a musician
for a long time and i didn't know that
yeah and i i got i i got good quickly
and i joined a rock band when i was in
eighth grade and we we played i grew up
in la so we played on the sunset strip i
was like 14 and i had at 14 you were
playing with a rock group on the sunset
stream yeah it was i had braces and i
was uh not i thought it would you know
it would be it would make me cool the
thing was the other guys were these
they couldn't play their instruments at
all but they were they were like six
feet tall surfer
long blonde hair never wore shirts or
shoes and they would just get up and
basically hit a cord and then like point
to me and then i was like rain man like
i was just like so like
and i was looking down
and i'd look up and you know they would
there would be like an orgy on the stage
with them and i would just still be
stolen
so your job was pretty much to know
music yeah so that they could get it on
with your ladies they would be like
brown and then i would just solo and i'd
look up and it was like a you know scene
from the bockeye yeah there was a lot of
a lot of that and it it all evaded me
somehow and i kept thinking i'll just
get better and i got better i played
even faster
and uh and they they just had more and
more sex
yeah so it worked out for them for them
it worked out for them yeah